good afternoon
seven things a man over 50 should be doing
and ladies
if your man is over 50
this is what you should be making him do
check your balls
why do we check our balls
make sure there's nothing untoward going on
down there
it's the first sign of testicular cancer
number one
number two
get your chest
prostrate
checked yearly
it's not that comfortable
we know that for 20 seconds
we've got a doctor with our
he's asking us to bend our knees
and lie on our side
take a nice deep breath
it's great in it
but why because it's the early signs
that we can get a sort of prostrate
cancer out
No.3 check your blood pressure regularly
why because imagine boiling a kettle
and not allowing it to turn off
it blows in the end
so the blood pressure is our silent killer
anything above 135 140
hypertension
go and see your gp No.5
sorry No.4
cholesterol
should be around
about five
and below
why cholesterol
is the fatty subject
substance that float around in our art
arteries as they become more blocked
if something breaks off
it can go to our head stroke
heart heart attack
check your cholesterol
next one gut health
as a 55 year old man
I'm fair to say that I've abused my body
over the years
the gut is the second brain
look after your guts
imagine what you're putting
through your intestines
through your guts
day in day out
it's important to look after your guts
look for a supplement that will help with that
go and work on synergy
synergy worldwide com
got some great products on there
number five
number six
self care
we tend to look after everybody else
before we look after ourselves
let's spin it around
on our heads
if we look after ourselves better
we can look after others better
think of it
self care
do something
you enjoy
whatever it might be
go get yourself a matter
it's good
it doesn't matter
just go enjoy something
it helps with your mental health
brings me on to mental health
if you're struggling
speak to a mate
your mate will appreciate that happening
and I'm just gonna add one on to that
stay freaking healthy
move more exercise
whatever it is
we're not getting any younger
but what we're doing is helping ourselves
live longer
we want to maximize the last bit of our lives
and second half of our lives
staying active
helps with all the above
that I've just put
enjoy yourselves
any problems
drop me a dm cheers